a new year for many of us means it's
time to make resolutions but sticking
with them can be a challenge 2018 study
found only six percent of Americans
fully stocked to their resolutions New
York Times bestselling author James
clear offers a roadmap to lifestyle
change in his book atomic habits an easy
and proven way to build good habits and
break bad ones he's here to help us make
resolutions that will last
James clear good morning and happy New
Year to you good morning let me start
with the key what is the key to making a
good New Year's resolution well most of
the time when people make a new year's
resolution they're essentially making a
goal for themselves right the thought is
okay I want different outcomes this year
I want to lose weight or I want to
meditate more reduce stress I want to be
more productive but I think actually the
typical New Year's resolution focuses on
the wrong thing what I mean by that is
we think the outcome is the thing that
needs to change but actually it's the
habits or the system the process behind
the outcome so for example if you have a
messy room you look around the room and
you think oh this is so cluttered I need
a clean room but if you get motivated
and clean the room for an hour you have
a clean room for now but if you don't
change the sloppy messy packrat habits
that led to a dirty room in the first
place then you end up in the same place
and it's similar with New Year's
resolutions we think what I need is to
feel less stress or what I need is to
have a written book or what I need is to
lose weight but actually what we really
need are the habits and the systems
behind those things yes I won't ask you
about to have a written book which is a
little too personal to me but if it's
clean the room let's say or lose weight
how then do I wire my life with good
habits so I think the first thing to
focus on is not the outcome that you
want but the type of person you want to
become so if you take losing weight a
lot of people may say oh I want to lose
40 pounds or something like that but the
question asked is who is the type of
person that could lose weight well maybe
it's the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts and so your new year's
resolution becomes not to lose a certain
amount of weight or to achieve a
particular goal but to be a certain type
of person and this is where I think
small habits are so useful because even
if doing something like 5 push-ups is
not enough to transform your body
overnight it is enough
cast a vote for being that kind of
person for being a fit person and so in
a sense it's like every action you take
as a vote for the kind of person you
believe that you are and so the first
task is to start casting votes for that
new identity and then worry about
ramping up the intensity later and is
the key word there action you're you're
giving yourself an action item whereas
clean the room or be a clean person or
be a thin person those are gargantuan
big things certain actions so you
translate that identity that you're
looking to build into a small action a
small vote that you can take so you know
things like doing five push-ups writing
one sentence meditating for sixty
seconds these don't sound like ambitious
New Year's resolutions but all of them
cast a vote for being a fit person or
becoming a writer or being a meditator
and ultimately when you get to the end
of the year what you want it's not to
have a particular result but to look at
yourself in a new way all right it will
vote not just in November but with our
actions James clear thanks so much thank
you